in other news tonight the covet 19
pandemic continues to impact businesses
all across the valley but things are
starting to ramp
back up over in henderson and the
chamber of commerce is hoping
recent development projects will keep
things moving in the right direction
orco mana filed this story earlier
tonight he explains that despite the
challenges
the future looks promising it's just the
uncertainty what's going to happen next
covet 19 continues to create several
unknowns for tim brooks he's the
co-owner of emerald island casino in
henderson one of many local businesses
hit hard by the pandemic
so we were forced to furlough over 135
people
the toughest thing during the shutdown
for
us as business owners was the fact that
we had to let our employees know that we
were no longer able to employ them
located in henderson's water street
district emerald island casino is
starting to bounce back
overall things are good the henderson
chamber of commerce is ready for this
area to get back to the boom town it was
pre-pandemic
ceo scott mulrah says there's progress
on the horizon
we've had a lot of continued optimism
and growth in some parts of the economy
like in west henderson there's a lot of
significant development projects still
occurring here on water street even
there's the lifeguard arena which is
just down the street from us
which will be opening likely next week
to the public
there are still challenges including
capacity restrictions but milwrath hopes
major projects such as lifeguard arena
and the raiders practice facility will
bring a boost to nearby businesses
that's going to bring traffic and
community
to all of these hubs and while the
future is still uncertain brooks says
he's optimistic about the outlook
we believe that the best is ahead of us
orco mana 8 news now
the city of henderson has created a
covid19 business resource guide for
struggling businesses
we have a link to that on our website
eight newsnow dot com